un verdict qui pourrait avoir des
conséquences sur le prochain scrutin
présidentiel
la cour suprême brésilienne a confirmé
hier l'annulation des condamnations pour
corruption de l'ancien président lula
une première victoire qui le relance
dans l'arène politique
c'était un très gros mensonge mais mes
avocats ont prouvé que c'était une
imposture
le juge a menti les avocats a menti la
police fédérale a menti pour m'éloigner
de la campagne électorale maintenant je
suis prêt pour le combat en 2017 et 2018
luiz inacio da silva dit lula est
condamné à plus de 12 ans de prison pour
corruption et blanchiment dans la sphère
petrobras il est emprisonné inéligible à
la présidentielle de 2010 8 en février
2019 il est condamné dans une autre
affaire à 12 ans et 11 mois de prison
pour corruption et blanchiment dans la
sphère de la rénovation de l'une de ses
propriétés
mais le 8 mars dernier un juge du
tribunal suprême fédéral annule ses
condamnations estimant que le tribunal
qui l'a condamné dans les deux procès
n'était pas compétent la cour suprême a
confirmé hier le verdict confirmant
aussi l'égibilité de l'ex président à un
troisième mandat
alors que j'aï rebelles sun araw lorgne
déjà vers la présidentielle de 2022
les hostilités sont d'ores et déjà
ouvertes entre les deux probables
candidats comparer des ministres de lula
avec nos ministres c'est lula est de
retour par un vote direct un vote
vérifiables d'accord mais imaginer ce
que sera le futur du brésil avec le
genre de personne qu'il va faire entrer
dans l'exécutif
les juges de la cour suprême nino sont
pas l'ancien syndicaliste sur le fond et
devront décider s'ils ordonnent le
transfert du dossier un autre tribunal
en attendant une possible
l'officialisation de sa candidature
lula affûte ses armes face à bolton a
row dont la cote de popularité
s'effondre avec le coronavirus que son
adversaire avait qualifié de plus gros
génocide de
histoire du brésil locaux vides 19,6 a
fait à ce jour plus de 365 milles morts